yeah it definitely matters because like
money security like Financial Security
is important to me but as long as like
we have enough money to I don't know go
on dates and like do like concerts like
fun stuff no it doesn't really matter if
he has goals like if the salary is not
amazing right now but he has goals for
himself and you know he's working
towards something that's important to me
but everyone's in different places at
different times so I feel like immediate
salary just
as long as we could still have fun
if his bills are paid and he treats me
right I don't think money should be an
object because it doesn't last forever
no salary not too much I'd say like same
answer as his job title it doesn't
really matter what what you're making
right now but if you're ambitious and
um you have like high expectations for
yourself and high goals for yourself
then that's very attractive
it is important because you know for for
me as a female I plan to be making a
certain amount at a certain age and um
the man that I expect to be with I want
him to be a hustler and a go-getter too
and you know the harder you work the
more you work the higher you're going to
move up the more your salary is gonna
okay is there a is there a number that
stands out to you as like a decent
salary like something that you would be
like okay he needs to make this much
money
I don't think there's a number in mind
um especially for right now that I would
say if
if he's not ever making more than
say a hundred thousand dollars then I
would be a little bit worried about our
future
I asked you I got the answer you said
wait I waited I got the answer I shut
the [ __ ] up now let's keep listening oh
wow but let's keep listening
I would say enough
to
level life of leisure in a sense like
not have to worry about your
rent your utilities stuff like that but
also
um that's reasonable
obviously a more desirable desirable man
would be able to take care of my of our
kids of myself of our older parents so I
would say somewhere between
uh 400k
forever like
there's no bar
oh
yo oh my God this shit's gonna Redfield
me so [ __ ] hard where do you live Oh
my days and it's just this much we're in
2022 like where do you live they've been
said 400 to the bar goes wherever if you
don't get the [ __ ] up out of here with
your average looking Oh my days get get
her out of here bro and you saw how
reasonable everybody sounded oh yeah you
know it doesn't really matter fantastic
Cindy uh yeah I make 50k not a [ __ ]
chance you loser wow
100K you guys understand how high that
is that's like less than one percent of
23 if I were to be dating a man right
now at 23 did she say 23 she don't know
nothing
this is gonna be bad because I'm not
expecting something very brilliant out
of this but let's go but but surprise me
I might be super wrong 80k is pretty
good 80 to 100K at 23.
do you understand that you get to that
level of money like around 40
and a lot of most [ __ ] out
there at 40 are not going to be at that
level you understand that so beep game
so
that's what they want
that that's what women want they want
that
and then men are like well that's not
possible because I'm gonna make like 75
or tops 80 if I really get there but you
want above that but men need to step up
oh we shall
is what I'd be looking for
um
yeah somewhere around 80 to 100K in your
mid-20s
the [ __ ] delusion most of my
[ __ ] I know in their mid-20s
are still in school
those those are gonna hold on those are
gonna eventually
make a hundred
a hundred like a hundred twenty by the
time they're 40
at 25 are still in school put your goofy
ass uh I think six figures is definitely
decent for it's a little you gotta work
hard for it nowadays but for an income
you know to create a family and things
of that nature like at least 100 000 is
acceptable okay and you [ __ ]
don't understand why Andrew Tate exists
you don't understand why the red pill
exists
you don't understand why these extremes
exist because you got that extreme
damn
is the response to that Hey listen
listen I don't agree with that extreme
but I don't agree with that extreme
either but they're the correlation
that's the reason why therapists slammed
for saying lonely men need to step up in
dating
hate mail from Men
why
[Music]
when all I'm doing is asking you
to be the best version of yourself
that's all that's
all I'm inviting you to do my brothers
all I'm inviting you to do
just be
the best version of yourself
what did he initially say so the rise of
lonely single men dating opportunities
for heterosexual men are diminishing as
relationship standards rise men
represent approximately 62 percent of
dating app users lowering their chances
for mention matches men need to address
skills deficient deficits to meet
healthier relationship expectation here
are the three broad Trends in the
relationship landscape that suggest a
heterosexual men are in for a rough road
dating apps sixty percent of users are
men and women are overwhelmed by the
number of options they have competition
online is fierce and lucky in-person
chance encounters with dream partners
are rare than ever I hear reoccurring
dating themes from women between the
ages of 25 and 45 they prefer men who
are emotionally available who are good
communicators and who share their values
skill deficits for men this means a
relationship skill Gap there's less
patience for poor communication skills
today the problem for men is that
emotional connection and this is the
lifeblood of long healthy long-term love
and it requires all the skills that
families
that families are not consistently
teaching young boys
level up your mental health game that
means getting into some individual
therapy to address your skill gaps
okay so so therapy
oh take care of your mental health that
means you know all your deficits that
you have communicating that's not just
that
that's a shortcut
it's a very big shortcut God damn I'm
not even going to the same place the
leadership principle is simple always
seek self-improvement
always seek
self-improvement simple to me it doesn't
get more complicated than that
so if I as a leader
am always seeking self-improvement
then why would I not look to my
relationships the people that I care
about the most
the people I say I love and not ask
myself how can I love these people
better
why would I not ask myself that unless I
was afraid
prayed that it meant something
it meant either I didn't know something
I needed to do something but something
needed to change something would have to
something would have to shift
but why not Embrace that I've never said
this but I've never seen a psychologist
who talk like a [ __ ] boy is there
something good about wanting to love the
people around June blower and all this
other stuff great but this is
he's not wrong in the sense that
he hasn't stated something that's untrue
he's wrong in the sense that he's
misrepresenting what the solution is to
the issue because he hasn't actually
brought up what the issue is there you
go we are at a weird intersection in
society
women's Financial levels has gone up
women's ability to have education
standards all these things have risen
whilst men have either stagnated or gone
downwards okay
now
we only have each other on this [ __ ]
planet people are saying I don't want to
lower my standards so I'd rather die
alone and some people are like I'll
never lower my standard so I'll take my
chances you got so many issues
intercepted and so why I hate what this
goober is doing okay
is he's just reducing the issue to one
thing which is better yourself go to
therapy actually it'll make your hinge
matches better it's genius you know it's
like it's like it's like it's like we
talk about the fact that vast majority
of self-deletians are men bring that up
men are struggling with certain issues
yeah and then all of a sudden I'll hear
like these big ass female content
creators be like well you know if toxic
masculinity wasn't Iran maybe you'd
still be I'm like God damn is that the
only issue is that the only issue
there's no cross map uh correlation
between [ __ ] economy going to the
[ __ ] and men dying no there's none of
that extreme Circle none of that it's
just toxic man it's the reducing of
men's issues to like these simple things
that I find distasteful and as somebody
who's a psychologist of all things
saying saying you need to [ __ ] level
up yeah a lot of girls have said that
and I actually just recently read the
statistic where only two percent of men
between the ages of 20 and 40 make six
figures and are over six feet which is
like like two of the things that women
typically say they want right but it's
crazy to think about the fact that
there's only two percent of men yeah
that are talking that much yeah I'll
take a short guy that makes a million
all day long this [ __ ] went more
ridiculous okay
all right awesome
the reason why I'm playing this is when
I hear goofy people like Greg Matos come
out here and write these articles about
the rights of lonely men and how they
need to up their skills it's such a
singular issue within the greater
Dynamic everything this is not mad at
women having higher standards this is
not me mad at men [ __ ] not doing but
it's none of that I'm saying this [ __ ]
is complicated this [ __ ] is complicated
think about the fact that some of these
women okay are now going to be the
primary Breadwinners right they're going
to be making six figures and above
fully capable
of sustaining a family themselves yet
now that they've made all this extra
money and sacrificed a lot of their
dating experiences and their
relationship life and their early
childbearing years okay now they
sacrifice that they still
even though they've usurped the gender
roles through their own choices do not
want to take the role that they should
have based off their income they're not
ready to take the man's role that the
men have always held in terms of being
the primary Breadwinner no they're
saying you got to be at my level
so
you have to understand this is
completely flipped the world upside down
in a lot of ways again
go make your money do whatever you want
but we gotta be honest about some of the
issues that exist in our dating
landscape and it's not just men need to
up their skills
I just want to say that and you look at
his comment section it's pretty much
exclusively female so yeah okay that's
the one I wanna Derek Jackson with a
degree
shout outs okay the green Jackson yes
and listen I don't trust anybody with
that [ __ ] kind of Boston New York
accent he got going on there so
um but yeah I just I can't stand a lot
of this stuff I just it's just
distasteful so you guys saw it yourself
people who think they're reasonable
aren't okay a lot of dudes who think
that they got reasonable demands aren't
it's kind of like that [ __ ] loser
who's making Tick Tock videos from his
mom's basement to talk about what a
woman's got to do for him bruh you
haven't even left her basement you don't
make no money why you telling what they
got to do for you right so
does a lot of that on socials
um and I think I think issues are
complicated so that's it what do you
think not because you got a degree that
you use contacts